I still take it over I am not prepared
for the 2020 presidential race well why
would you be you know it's a million
years away it's a million years away
it's something like 500 or 800 days away
3,800 Democratic candidates it's
ridiculous I'm not ready for it yeah
it's happening too fast everyone's out
there promoting themselves Kamala Harris
just announced that she supports
legalizing marijuana yeah
as a result she's already won the
California primary and it's legal here I
know people were just like whatever
she's very you know speaking of drugs I
want to talk about El Chapo for a second
el chapo was convicted yeah Wow it is a
pro el chapo crap that's shocking well I
need my supply where am I gonna get it
now there's a really lukewarm famous
drug you know merchants caught crowd
kind of bummed
was that saying about our country I know
no but scary yeah
el chapo was convicted here's the scary
thing he is a master of escape you know
that yeah in the past he's gotten out of
two high-security prisons and even more
impressive he once got out of his
contract with 24-hour Fitness which I
thought that's hard to do thank you
when I get a laugh on one I like I'm
going to shake the front end those hands
yeah this is I just want to mention this
drug story - I don't know if you heard
this is a true story in Texas a woman
who snuck into an abandoned building to
smoke pot discovered a tiger being kept
in a cage yes yet the Tigers been
rescued and the woman has stopped
smoking pot because I'll be honest she
no handshakes on that one but she [ __ ]
herself passing